Traductor: Yoshinori Casas
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Antes de la creación de la humanidad,
los dioses griegos ganaron una batalla
contra los Titanes, una raza de gigantes.
La mayoría de Titanes fueron destruidos
o llevados al infierno eterno de Tártaro.
Pero el Titán Prometeo,
nombre que significa previsión,
convenció a su hermano Epimeteo
para pelear junto con los dioses.
Como agradecimiento,
Zeus confió a los hermanos
la tarea de crear
todos los seres vivientes.
Epimeteo tenía que distribuir los regalos
de los dioses entre las criaturas.
A algunos, les dio el vuelo;
a otros, la capacidad
de moverse por el agua
o correr por el pasto.
A las bestias les dio escamas brillantes,
pelaje suave,
y garras afiladas.
Mientras tanto, Prometeo formó
del barro al primer humano.
Los formó a imagen de los dioses,
pero Zeus decretó
que ellos deberían ser mortales
y adorar a los habitantes
del monte Olimpo desde abajo.
Zeus consideró a los humanos criaturas
subordinadas, vulnerables a los elementos
y dependientes de la protección
de los dioses.
Sin embargo, Prometeo vio en sus nuevas
creaciones un propósito mayor.
Cuando Zeus le pidió decidir
cómo harían los sacrificios,
el astuto Prometeo planeó un truco
que le daría ventajas a los humanos.
Mató un toro y lo dividió en dos partes
para presentarlo ante Zeus.
Por un lado, ocultó la suculenta
carne y la piel
bajo el desagradable vientre del animal.
Por otro lado, escondió los huesos
debajo de una capa gruesa de grasa.
Cuando Zeus escogió la que parecía
la mejor parte para él,
se enfureció al darse cuenta
del engaño de Prometeo.
Lleno de rabia, Zeus prohibió
el uso de fuego en la tierra,
ya fuera para cocinar carne
o para otro propósito.
Pero Prometeo se reusó a ver
a su creación sin este recurso.
Entonces, escaló el monte Olimpo
para robar fuego
del taller de Hefesto y Atena.
Escondió las llamas en un hinojo hueco
y la llevó de forma segura a las personas.
Esto les dio el poder de explotar
la naturaleza para su propio beneficio
y básicamente dominar el orden natural.
Con el fuego, los humanos pudieron
cuidarse por su cuenta con comida y calor.
Pero también pudieron forjar armas
y hacer la guerra.
Las llamas de Prometeo catalizaron
el avance de la civilización.
Cuando Zeus vio esta escena,
se dio cuenta de lo sucedido.
Prometeo había herido de nuevo su orgullo
y subvertido su autoridad.
Furioso, Zeus impuso un castigo brutal.
Prometeo debía ser encadenado
a un acantilado eternamente.
Cada día, recibía la visita
de un buitre que comía su hígado
y cada noche se regeneraba su hígado
para ser atacado de nuevo en la mañana.
Aunque Prometeo permaneció
en agonía perpetua,
nunca expresó arrepentimiento
por su acto de rebelión.
Su resistencia frente a la opresión
lo hizo una figura amada en la mitología.
También fue famoso por su espíritu
travieso e inquisitivo,
y por el conocimiento, progreso y poder
que trajo a las manos humanas.
Él es también una figura recurrente
en el arte y la literatura.
En el drama lírico de Percy Bysshe Shelley
"Prometeo liberado",
el autor imagina a Prometeo
como un héroe romántico
que escapa y sigue difundiendo
empatía y conocimiento.
Shelley escribió sobre el protagonista:
"Prometeo es la forma
de la más alta perfección
de naturaleza moral e intelectual,
impulsado por los motivos
más puros y sinceros
para el mejor y más noble fin".
Su esposa Mary concibió a Prometeo
más como una figura de precaución
y subtituló su novela
"Frankenstein: El Prometeo moderno".
Esto sugiere el daño de corromper
el orden natural
y sigue siendo relevante
para los temas éticos
que rodean hoy
a la ciencia y la tecnología.
Como héroe, rebelde o tramposo,
Prometeo es un símbolo de la capacidad
para tomar poderes de la naturaleza
y, en última instancia,
nos recuerda que los actos individuales
tienen el potencial de cambiar el mundo.